So we saw in the
previous video how
we can solve linear optimization
problems in LibreOffice.
Let's now try to get
some intuition for what's
going on by visualizing
our problem.
Since we only have two
decisions, R and D,
we can visualize our
constraints in two dimensions.
We'll plot D on the x-axis,
and R on the y-axis.
We first have
non-negativity constraints,
so R and D are both
greater than zero.
We can plot the capacity
constraint, R + D less than
or equal to 166, which is
shown as the red line here.
Our solution has to be
to the left of this line
according to this constraint.
Now, let's add in our
demand constraints.
The regular seats should be less
than the demand of 100, which
requires the solution to
be below this blue line.
And the discount seats should
be less than the demand of 150,
which requires
the solution to be
to the left of this green line.
Taken together, our
constraints define
what we call our "feasible
space" or the space
of all possible values
that our decisions can
take according to
our constraints.
To find the optimal solution
now in our feasible space,
we have to use the
objective, 617*R + 238*D.
We can plot this objective
in our feasible space.
So to know how many
seats we should
sell to achieve a
certain revenue,
we can see different
values of this line.
So to achieve a
revenue of $20,000,
our solution has to be somewhere
on this line in our feasible
space.
To achieve a revenue of
$40,000, our solution
has to be somewhere on this
line in our feasible space.
And to achieve a
revenue of $60,000,
our solution has to be somewhere
on this line in our feasible
space.
Since the revenue is increasing
as we move this line up
and our goal is to
maximize the revenue,
our optimal solution
will be where
this line can't go
any further and still
be in our feasible space.
So our optimal solution
is at this point
with a revenue of $77,408.
As we can see here,
the solution is
dependent on how the
feasible space was defined.
In the next video,
we'll see what
happens if our capacity
and demands change.